two steps forward one step back may just
be the best description of america's
game plan in afghanistan over the many
many years they've been there the latest
example being more troops are now being
sent over in order to bring the troops
home
you know to protect the troops for a
short period of time
there will have to be some additionally
additional enabling
capabilities added to afghanistan
to again help affect a safe orderly
and deliberately planned drawdown of
everybody
by the president's deadline here by by
sept by early september
potential adversaries should know that
if they attack us in our withdrawal
we will defend ourselves and our
partners with all the tools at our
disposal
they came they saw and little has
changed
the taliban is still a dominant force in
afghanistan and not even the u.s has any
delusions about who might step into the
vacuum they leave behind
democratic senator jeanne shaheen of new
hampshire recently said quote it's
difficult to see a scenario
that doesn't end in civil war or a
taliban takeover
unquote is that just afghanistan's
problem and who cares
look uh jake that is certainly a
possible scenario
i fear uh that a couple of years from
now we're going to look back
and we're going to remember that
whenever there are ungoverned spaces in
the muslim world
extremists fill them a pretty grim
acknowledgement after almost
two decades of effort the u.s is more or
less passing the buck to those in the
region
the message being we know we're leaving
room for terrorists to possibly breed
you better do something about it because
we're done trying oh and the taliban
have already taken the opportunity to
issue threats over the delay of the
withdrawal
not exactly a defeated sentiment he says
if something happens
it'll be unfortunate for the u.s all
responsibility for the prolongation of
war
death and destruction will be on the
shoulders of those who committed this
violation
sure sounds like america's longest war
ever isn't over yet
and how could anyone believe it was when
over and over even as the body count
continued to rise both among american
soldiers and
afghan civilians and the financial costs
skyrocketed
president after president failed to
actually bring the troops home
despite all their promises this year we
will bring
america's longest war to a responsible
end
it's time after all these years to go
and to bring our people back home
and american leadership means ending the
forever war in afghanistan
and after 20 years of value valor
and sacrifice it's time to bring those
troops home
and here we are biden has set another
date this time it's the 20th anniversary
of 9 11.
but is this the end because his
administration also insisted the us is
an abandoning afghanistan
and has promised to remain quote deeply
engaged in the country
another step back then it seems
the anti-war answer coalition's brian
becker thinks that the scheduled u.s
withdrawal from afghanistan
doesn't necessarily mean the troops will
head home
the u.s has a permanent military machine
it has 800 military bases when the u.s
says it's
leaving a country it's not like the old
days when a war
ended in the american troops demobilized
as happened up until the end of world
war
ii because we have a permanent
military-industrial complex it just
really means that these
troops will be redeployed the taliban
can now simply wait the united states
out
and intensify the harassment of the
attacks on the existing
afghan military and afghan police forces
these attacks are going to intensify
the taliban is going for it they know
they basically won the war
the us has to at some point leave
even though as i said they won't really
really leave the region they'll be
nearby
i mean i think the writing is on the
wall there's going to be
either a taliban government or a
government of so-called national unity
which will be dominated by the taliban
you